SANDRA OH
I will say, Awkwafina is terrible.
She breaks all the time!
SANDRA OH and AWKWAFINA
[Laughing]
AWKWAFINA
This film is about
two sisters reconnecting,
based on who they are now as adults.
TERRY MCTEER
This is fun.
AWKWAFINA
I'm such a huge fan of Sandra.
To actually play sisters was so cool.
-Hit the button.
-Annie!
-I can't hear you!
-There's a button there!
ANNE
Hit the god--
-[Doorbell dings]
-[Sighs]
SANDRA OH
This is one of the best experiences
of my career.
JENNY
This is my destiny!
ANNE
[Laughs]
SANDRA OH
I remember talking to Awkwafina
and saying, "What do you think
about me playing Jenny?"
And she said...
"You can play
whatever the **** you want."
[Crash]
JESSICA YU
Sandra and Awkwafina
know each other better than anyone.
The way that they are tuned
to each other is quite spectacular.
-[Yelling]
-[Screaming]
ANNE
Jenny! Look out!
-[Car horn]
-[Screaming]
[Tires screeching]
JEN D'ANGELO
They had such great ideas
to make this even more funny.
JENNY
I think I might have manifested this.
SANDRA OH
Awkwafina and I were improvising so much.
AWKWAFINA
She took the improv a little far, I think.
At one point,
Sandra put her foot in my mouth.
AWKWAFINA
[Laughs]
SANDRA OH
I hope that people
get a sliver of how fun
it was to shoot it.
TV AUDIENCE
[Cheering]
-[Ketchup bottles crashing]
-[Laughter]